Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie huge news, you
guys may have seen all the craziness about
Deadpool maybe being in the Wolverine movie,
the actors came out.
So I'm and explain what's going on and why
everyone's freaking out in honor of Stan Lee's
birthday there's a new round of the Spider-Man
giveaway.
All you have to do to enters be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything.
So what's going on.
People are saying the Deadpool's going to
be in the movie the actors came out and said
no that's not the case.
Prisoner 24601 is going to be on a solo mission
the just Ryan Reynolds poking fun at the fact
that Hugh Jackman was inlay Ms. but then James
Mangold the director came out was like you
know.
Thank you for responding to this and then
Hugh Jackman just stacked on top of that and
was like yeah with these guys said.
So what is happening is that it was reported
that Deadpool had shot a scene with the new
Deadpool to director for the new Logan movie
that's being released in March with the Logan
movie is now in post production like they're
just finishing some special effects, it's
is supposed to be like the smaller more self-contained
movie, just sort of a book in the Hugh Jackman's
time as Wolverine in the Wolverine character
that he originated so that Fox going forward
can do whatever they want to with the character
when maybe he doesn't plane anymore they as
well as Hugh Jackman have been saying for
a while now that this can be his last time
to put the clause on.
So just don't believe anything to you actually
see it but for now it seems like it's going
to be his last Wolverine movie.
The rumors just saying that even though Deadpool
to isn't going to be shooting for a while
they just know it's sort of like a test for
the new director and just to do something
fun for the fans there putting some Deadpool
as a bit of attack at the end of the movie
and it's not really can have a lot to do with
the plot of Logan like okay I'm in a play
this clip here.
There was a clip of Deadpool that they released
in Japan after X-Men apocalypse came out,
just to make fun of that movie more so than
Deadpool did in the actual Deadpool movie,
so here go Ojai Japan Deadpool here surprised
I just wanted to share with you my two cents
on five things you may have missed and X-Men
apocalypse trailer, I know, just thinking
and after credit scene for the trailer for
the film did that for movies right well not
everyone makes to the end of Fox movies so
now were doing it after trailers will be set
in the 80s and apparently apocalypse kicks
Professor X's ask forgetting to wake him up
before he cocoa number two page apocalypse
when Quicksilver disclosed mystique that magneto
is his father and he's a fan of Canadian supergroup
rushed so many plot twists refund that sidewalk
is looking girl using a superpower katana
and I'm a horrible looking then using a katana
Twin Cities number four looks like they're
introducing a Japanese mutant with Ginsu knives
coming out of his hands.
Let's see how that goes number five this wasn't
really in the trailer but important for you
to know the newest addition to the super dysfunctional
X-Men family immediate Deadpool comes out
Japan on June 1, I definitely so be there
June 1 so you can see how they basically just
took like the X-Men apocalypse trailer and
then you shot like a little extra Deadpool
seen in the just jammed it on the end of the
trailer you have to imagine that that's what
was reported about this Deadpool cameo in
the Wolverine movie.
But then fans came out and were like oh my
God, it's gonna be a team up can be so amazing
say it's true.
And then Ryan Reynolds responded with something
like this and said no sadly prisoner 24601
is on a solo mission, so what Ryan Reynolds
is saying is is that he is not going to be
teaming up with Wolverine in the Logan movie
he's not saying anything about an end credit
scene or any kind of end tag with Deadpool
like there's no confirmation or denial about
any of that going on in the director James
Mangold the reason why he was like oh my God,
thank you so much for doing this is because
he doesn't want fans to go see the new Wolverine
movie expecting to see a Deadpool team up
and then be really disappointed and really
pissed off when they don't see that.
So they're just clarifying that this is the
Logan movie.
But there will probably be of funny Deadpool
seen for the fans at the end that will have
nothing to do with the Logan movie.
It'll just be like something that they jammed
on at the end three maybe make fun of Hugh
Jackman just pokes fun at the X-Men franchise
in general.
So the still locking down there cable actor
there's like a number of different things
they could do with that.
Post credit scene because not expecting it
to be super long it might just be something
like the Ferris Buehler Post credit scene
during the first Deadpool movie, you still
here it's over will always expecting the teaser
for Deadpool to what we don't have that kind
of money expecting Sam Jackson show off eyepatch
and sauce is leather number, so let me know
in the comments what you think about all this
like what kind of Deadpool seen did they tack
on to the end of Logan like who is he making
fun of Izzy just making fun of Hugh Jackman
is he going to be poking fun.
It all the X-Men is he going to be teasing
stuff for the Deadpool sequel like he did
in that there's Buehler seen like you laugh,
but they haven't confirmed cable or anything
like that.
It just like drop life filled said that when
they were originally talking about the first
Deadpool movie.
He was like definitely do not put cable in
the first movie save them for the next movies
of the primary they get the cable eventually
but you know nobody knows how well a movie
is gonna do told actually comes out.
So they were kind of just having a little
bit of fun with that scene.
Although it did turn out to be prophetic like
the movie blew up became the biggest rated
R movie of all time.
So of course are going to do a sequel of course
are going to put cable and it.
But what about Hugh Jackman like if he's not
can it be in the X-Men movies anymore are
they still going to do seems like that so
him to play this clip where Hugh Jackman was
doing some other movie Ryan Reynolds help
promoted just because they're good friends
ended up trolling each other's characters
Wolverine origins that version of Deadpool
as well as Green Lantern little bit.
So just watch this video just enjoy performing
their own stunts yes do you do all your own
acting.
It's a sex things I do the best.
That's where the craft is Thea, it's to do
a good marriage did you guys get any notes
in the studio so at his mouth shut.
Make laser shoot from his eyes.
You know Adina, but also to be a great idea
story totally makes sense Parsifal was upset.
Do you ever age.
Not since 2000 night gorgeous.
So what I think going forward.
You know, unless Hugh Jackman just changes
his mind and wants to come back and do more
Wolverine cameos is they'll continue to do
stuff like this because Hugh Jackman is still
gonna keep making movies with Fox Studios,
so that means that you'll probably see more
stuff like this can or he just like pokes
fun at Ryan Reynolds because now he's the
big man on campus whereas here.
Once upon a time, Wolverine was the biggest
character of Fox like before the days of Deadpool,
Wolverine was like the one guy that you can
count on you.
Put them in a movie people will go see that
movie now.
That's kind of like the Deadpool thing like
you put Deadpool in a movie and it's like
holy shit we gotta go see this, so none of
this is anything about what the future of
the main X-Men franchise is going to be this
still kind of reworking that behind-the-scenes
ramping up for a dark Phoenix arc.
But it sounds like they're going to be reimagining
rebooting certain elements of the continuity
iron out all the wrinkles so that going forward
they make bands that both critics and fans
are really excited about because it sounds
like a lot of the fans really enjoy all these
movies, but it just does not help when critics
Savage or movie, no matter which studio your
app you know whether it's DC whether it's
marble whether it's Fox like everybody making
these movies wants to make a good movie.
So don't be surprised if they delay the next
X-Men movie for like another year, just to
give them extra time to work out of script.
I'm not talking about Deadpool that still
humming along like everybody's totally happy
with that right now those you asking about
a new Logan trailer new Deadpool footage I'm
not expecting anything until at least the
Super Bowl they might drop a little bit of
stuff before then though.
So just because they're going to be using
a lot of Deadpool to promote the Logan movie,
you know, in a roundabout way like I said
with Hugh Jackman, and Ryan Reynolds just
having fun with each other the probably start
doing that, during January ramping up to another
like big Logan trailer during the Super Bowl.
So get hype about that.
I think it's gonna be a really awesome movie.
I'm really excited about the Logan movie souls
are hearing a whole lot about the Deadpool
sequel, really soon.
Like they probably already found there cable
and just haven't chose to announce them yet.
But as we all continued to say happy birthday
to Stanley is Rick and his birthday for like
the rest the week when you're 94.
You get like an entire week to celebrate your
birthday.
So just try to imagine what his cameos going
to be in the next movie.
They were hyping it up on his actual birthday
yesterday like Stanley cameo ever is like
he's in the strip club announcing the chastity
character so I will say congratulations to
this week's Spider-Man giveaway winner Richard
Parker you and a $20 Amazon gift card be sure
to private message me on the back and my channel
so I can get your contact details.
There's a new round now announce the winner
the next time I post a Marvel video so what
can happen next is is is a couple big things
that just drop, there's new flash season three
the sum game of thrones that I want to post
their Superman versus deathstroke so there's
all kinds of Civil War stuff going on to,
so I'll try to get that stuff out as fast
as possible.
Whole bunch of comic book stuff happening
to ring in the new year make you feel little
bit better about life in general while you
guys wait for that to post you can click here
for new Spider-Man homecoming footage and
you can click here to learn all about Spider-Man
upgrades during avengers infinity war.
Thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!